hey everybody welcome back to this
modern building creation series it's not
really a series per se but I like to
pretend that there's a little bit of a
continuity going on here and in this
second build I'm gonna be working on
another Dutch inspired modern skyscraper
building but before I head into this
whole time-lapse and explain how I'm
doing everything just gonna kind of run
that in the background and talk about
something which is perhaps a little bit
of an elephant in the room right now
which I definitely need to address and
that is the fact that I am not using
glass in this video but somehow by
miracle it has been announced by
frontier that they're adding it into the
game and that announcement was a few
days ago the update is gonna come a few
days in the future as I'm speaking right
now and I built this building a few
weeks ago now initially when I started
this series it was something that I
wanted to do for a super long time like
I believe I've said in the first episode
it's something that I always wanted to
do I just was kind of hoping that phones
here would maybe add actual glass into
the game and at some point I just kind
of lost all of that hope I decided to
just make this series anyway and just
settle with the art primitives because
at this point I pretty much gave up all
my hope that fonts here would add glass
into the game although at the same time
it was also perhaps a little bit of a
jab since I still wanted that sweet
glass so recently I've just been kind of
[ __ ] posting on Twitter about like
posting minecraft pictures of Minecraft
having glass and being like gee I wish
every game had this kind of thing and I
don't know if my if my shitposting works
or if frontier was just being cheeky
behind the scenes the entire time but
we've got glass in the game and it's
coming in a few days so normally I know
I don't talk too much about the updates
but I am just too goddamn excited about
this edition not to talk about it in
this series and obviously it's also kind
of relevant because this series would be
a lot better where they're actually
glass in the game so because this
building is made before the update is
coming out and how we don't even know
what this glass is gonna look like at
the moment it is still using all of
these wall pieces and
kind of tricks to try and make
everything look a little bit classy but
I have to say if it is in the game and
if it's feasible
I would love to revisit these buildings
and actual glass to them and actually do
a little bit more in this series because
so far it's just been a little bit of an
experiment to see to what extent you can
really you know make modern buildings in
planet coaster even though the game is
not supposed to be no for modern
buildings whatsoever but I think with
the newest updates there is a big shift
in that and I think the fact that the
update is called the studio updates and
that they're ending all of these studio
features I think means that they're
definitely gonna add a lot of versatile
elements into the game and things which
can be used not just for modern
buildings but also backstage areas in
theme parks or if you want to make a
Disney or universal style studio park so
yeah I'm definitely excited about this
update even if it doesn't really seem
like a traditional typical theme park
theme I think it's a lot more versatile
and flexible than that now to leave that
intro behind and actually go into the
actual building process which has been
going on for a while now I'm ready I
guess this building is mostly inspired
again by modern Dutch architecture
mostly Rotterdam it's not much of a
secret then I always lurk on places like
skyscraper city and just kind of check
out all the developments I don't really
have much to offer there I'm not
particularly knowledged and I don't
really follow these kinds of things too
much in real life but I think it's a
super interesting topic and so it's
something that I really like and I've
barely ever done in planet coaster and
this one in particular this Tower in
particular was mostly inspired by the
Somme happen in Rotterdam which is a new
apartment building which they're
hopefully gonna start building this year
which is planned to be the tallest
building in the Netherlands with just
over 200 meters it's actually not that
tall but for the Netherlands it's quite
a big deal so that thing's been on my
mind quite a bit and the basic structure
of this tower was a little bit inspired
by it
it's got a similar color scheme and
similar balconies etc although I would
say this building is very different in a
sense that it has a very very definite
front and back so right here where the
crown hood has this curving rim of glass
facing towards whatever side its facing
towards is definitely the front of the
building and they've got some definite
sides and the back side as well which
the tower that this is inspired by it
doesn't have at all in fact the crown is
really different it's much more of a
well Empire State ish or NTT DoCoMo
building ish spire but obviously I
didn't want to do the exact same thing
so I decided to go for something just
slightly different it's also I believe a
bit of an interesting building in a
sense that it's not going to actually
beat that tall at all most of the
buildings in this park will be under 100
meters tall and so this one is going to
be 96 meters give or take which is
really yeah that's kind of short and I'm
trying to make this as tall as possible
by just making you know all of these
Viking nice Bowl balconies and in
general I feel like residential towers
and looking a little bit more taller
than office towers just because they
have all of this detailing on the
outside and this one I think with about
3.5 meter floors I think that's what I
went for it could have been 3.75 but in
any case floors that are way lower than
4 meters this ends up being a quite tall
looking building with a lot of floors
and yet it's just underneath a hundred
meters tall now most of the tower I've
divided into floors that should have
about 2 or 4 apartments should probably
be about for the vendor would be for
small apartments either that's or two
large ones I'm not really sure actually
how it should be split
I believe I went for four in the end
since near the end of the end of this
episode I'll be splitting the balconies
in half by placing a fence in the middle
but aside from those traditional typical
appts the entire tower the crown has
some some apartments in it and yeah well
yeah they're definitely penthouses
they're pretty huge and it's just one
penthouse per floor and then you've got
these awesome large windows right there
on the front where there should be
really amazing views of the imaginary
city that this might be located in I'm
not entirely sure what I would place
this in but that's really the general
idea so in a sense I kind of designed it
more with the idea of the apartments
inside in mind rather than the look that
it would have from the outside and so
I'm not the hugest fan of the way that
this building looks but um I'm still
kind of okay with it it's it's alright I
suppose although I do have to say
personally I do slightly prefer the
design of the building which I made in
the last episode of this which you can
see right next to this by the way the
reason that I am building this with the
other one next to it is to just kind of
keep it in scale on trying to not make
it out of scale with the other building
since I might and I have to emphasize
might hear her because I'm not entirely
sure if I'm actually gonna do this but I
might make a city or at least a small
neighborhood out of these buildings if I
end up making enough of them I think
that would be a really interesting
experiments and not many people have
tried building a city and planet coaster
yet and it's pretty something which I
feel you could try you know compared to
City skylines you obviously can't make
an entire city and you definitely can't
make it functional but at the very least
you have a lot of control over how every
single building looks and how all the
pavements and general street designs
look so I think it would be really
interesting to mess around with this
kind of thing you know even if it's not
my most popular series and if it's way
different from my usual content it is
something none kind of interested in
also that little spire in the end that
there'll be the the lightning rod for
the building I'll be also adding one
on the smaller building I think I just
did that actually and then there are
some other functional touches like these
H facts on the top for instance and this
is also really the kind of thing that I
am really curious for the studio update
for since they're earning a studio
update which kind of brings me the idea
that they're gonna add some kind of
walls and wall pieces like H facts or
other elements to make those like studio
esque buildings which I'm really hoping
for and that would definitely you know
give us way more options for these kind
of HVAC behind the scenes parts of
buildings which if I remember how
excited everyone was back in the Alpha
days to just get a few of these like air
conditioning units and stuff like that I
think it'd be amazing to see more stuff
in this kind of vein in the next update
as well and I'm actually kind of
surprised that I'm still adding stuff to
the top of the building at some point I
was I was thinking there wasn't really
enough interesting stuff going on on the
top of the building so I decided to kind
of redo that part of little bits have
have it a little bit more detail in
there and I also made the balconies have
that sort of like pattern across the
whole building it's something kind of
simple but I thought it would add a
little bit more interesting detailing to
the building one thing which I don't
usually like is if every single floor on
the building looks exactly the same so I
prefer when there is a little bit at
least a little bit of detailing or
slight variations added to every single
floor so in this case I went with the
black balconies but in the case of the
other Tower the balconies jut out a
little bit more the more you go up the
tower I should I should stop hitting my
pop filter you probably hear that in any
case you know I'm glad to have a pop
filter again glad to be back home and
not have to talk to dirty sock anymore
so at least we've got that in any case
gotta work on the foundations of the
building now and there was a really
interesting discussion going on in the
comment section of the last video
since I told everyone you know I don't
really know the English word for this
kind of thing as a Dutch word that
typically describes it but then I kind
of asked for like you know what's the
English word for this actually because I
had no idea turns out that there's not
really an English word with the direct
translation and the same meaning as the
planes in Dutch which kind of makes
sense usually when it comes to language
you never really have a direct
translation with the exact same
connotations but what I thought was
probably the most fitting for what I'm
trying to do here it's probably the word
podium I don't remember if anybody else
set this in the comments as well but I
remember dr. Beekman said it so thanks
dr. Bergman for giving that suggestion I
think podium is more or less what I'm
looking for I know some people do use
the word plinth as well in English but I
believe more commonly in English that's
associated with the the real bottom of a
floor like really the lower parts or
foundation of a building or even or
pillars or any architectural elements
and not necessarily over an entire
building the lower floors and I think
the lobby as well kind of misses the
meaning since that's usually just the
first floor just the entrance area and
in this case I really mean a low-rise
section which the entire rest of the
building is built on basically and the
lower the lower I Section also has a
little bit of a different style as you
can see here as well trying to connect
it a little bit more with street level
and I think it's slightly better I mean
many people probably agree it's it's
slightly better than having the whole
towers in the park approach where you
just have towers and these parts behind
them and trees everywhere it's a little
bit better to set the tower back a
little bit and have a lower section
which translates a little bit more to
some regular street architecture and
it's a little bit more on a human scale
so in this case I decided to go with a
low-rise section of four floors and
something which is built in a way that
it looks like there would be a
supermarket
something of that sort in the building
and there we go that's the addition of
these fences
I was actually struggling quite a bit
with this building trying to make it all
fit under the 4000 piece limits since
obviously the tower itself has quite a
bit of detailing and it's pretty tall
and it honestly it took a lot of cutting
away
that's the detailing at the bottom of
the tower it's actually fit in the four
thousand pieces that was quite a bit of
stuff that I had to do to optimize the
amount of pieces stuff like this where I
just kind of copied around the pillars
around the entire building but then
obviously there's a way to do it with
slightly less pillars and yeah that's
more or less just the way than I all
around the tower try to cut away the
piece count just to make it fit inside
the single blueprints honestly this is
also one of the reasons why I'm not
building these buildings taller than I
already am four for one I don't have
built the buildings too large since then
I wouldn't be able to fit much on a
planet coaster map which considering the
scale of a real city is also extremely
small and the second thing is just it's
hardly possible to making larger
buildings since it'll be very easy to
either go over the 4,000 piece counts or
just have a building that's large but
not really detailed and kind of likes
personality so yeah this is basically my
limits I'm basically selling my my roof
height limits to about a hundred metres
although if I do build a small city out
of it at least a single district like a
business district or something I would
like to have one like landmark one
iconic building that sort of towers over
the rest and has an actual spire but
that's all just kind of you know future
plans where I'm not actually sure if
they're gonna happen at all although it
would be great I'm definitely looking
forward to seeing the glass in this game
and seeing how that's gonna look so
finally I obviously can't add an actual
supermarket into this building but I
don't want some basic level of detailing
here so I'm adding these small windows
on the sides which kind of look like
they could be maybe you know the the
backstage area the supermarkets whereas
the fall of the building itself
has a loft glass like a big entrance
would have and at the back of the
building is where ideally the space
would be for the trucks to load and
unload all of their stuff which the
supermarket needs so that's really the
idea behind it all so I wanted to have a
slightly different pattern on the back
just as a little experiments I do think
I prefer the pattern in the front but
it's still fun to kind of mess with
these things it's pretty easy to do but
it makes a pretty good impact on how the
building looks and finally obviously I
wanted to add a few plants to the
building although I couldn't I couldn't
really do much with that because these
counts in any case that's it for this
episode so thank you for watching and I
hope to make a next time
in which case see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]